بعد سته ايام على زلزال كهرمان مراش
المدمر تدخل قافله مساعدات اموميه مكونه
من 22 شاحنه عبر معبر باب الهواء الحدود
مع تركيا
حمولتها مساعدات طبيه وخيام وهي اول قافله
مخصصه لمواجهه اذار الزلزال تدخل الى شمال
غرب سوريا الدفاع المدني اتهم صراحه للامم
المتحده والمجتمع الدوليه بالتخاذل عن مد
يد العون فالمساعدات تاخرت توخلت من
المعدات الثقيله الضروريه للعمليات الاكثر
الحاحا اي انقاذ الارواح
حتى مع هذا ظرف الاستثنائي لا يبدو ادخال
المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا سهلا فمن
المقرر عقد جلسه لمجلس الامن لبحث فتح
معابر جديده لادخال المساعدات الامميه
فما هي طرق ادخال المساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا مناطق المعارضه المحاذيه لتركيا
لديها معبران رئيسيان هما باب الهواء في
ريف ادلب ومنه دخلت المساعدات الاخيره
والاخر هو باب السلامه في ريف حلب وهو
مغلق منذ سنوات لعدم تجديد التوفيد الاموي
لدخول المساعدات منه كما توجد معابر اخرى
يطلق عليها المعابر المدنيه التجاريه وهي
معبر جرابلس والراعي والحمام
وتجهيزها اقل من معبر باب الهوى وباب
السلامه وسمح تركيا باستخدامها لادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه المقدمه من المنظمات
المحليه او من دوله بعينها الطريقه
الثانيه هي ما يطلق عليه ادخال عبر خطوط
التماس اي ان تدخل المساعدات الامميه الى
مناطق السيطره النظام ثم تنقل الى مناطق
المعارضه النظام السوري كان وافق على
ايصال المساعدات حتى الى المناطق الخارجه
عن السيطره لكن المنسقه الامميه للشؤون
الانسانيه في سوريا قال ان المنظمه بحاجه
الى موافقات لدخول مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
وانه لم يسمح بادخال اي مساعدات من مناطق
التماس بين النظام والمعارضه لم يحدد
المسؤول الاممي الجهه التي منعت دخول
المساعدات ولا تلك التي لا بد من اذنها
الثابت ان شده زلزال وكارثيه نتائجى لم
تنجي السوريين من الحسابات السياسيه في
ظرف دولي معقد